[Music]
eric is with us in lansing michigan hi
eric welcome to the ramsey show
hello gentlemen uh mr ramsay it is an
absolute honor sir so uh thank you thank
you opportunity to speak with you and uh
thank you for your backwoods hillbilly
wisdom because you've changed my family
uh we've been debt free house and all
for a little while now so thank you very
much sir way to go man so you own a
house debt-free way to go yes so i have
a real estate question i'm curious what
37 year old dave would say
so my in-laws currently have two houses
one in michigan and one in florida
they winter in florida so they're
snowbirds
they no longer want the maintenance and
upkeep of a house here in michigan so
they're selling it
my wife and i we've been looking at
purchasing a lake house
so my in-laws came to us with the
proposition of gifting us 50 cash
towards a down payment on a lake house
uh the understanding is that they would
live with us or live at the lake house
during the summer months for three to
four months
and
the house would then be in our name
solely
so we have been saving for a house we
don't obviously don't have you know the
other 50 remaining but i'm curious what
your thoughts are on this
wow
very generous of them yeah
yes we have a very good relationship
okay so you're they're going to give you
how much money
fifty percent
what is that how much money is now
well i i don't wanna go over four
hundred thousand total for the purchase
okay so they're gonna give you two
hundred thousand dollars in return they
get to live in the lake house in the
summer which by the way is the only time
you can use it can you visit there can
you visit your lake house in the summer
yeah absolutely while they're there
we're looking at
you guys can go up and put the boat in
the water and all of you play and all of
you while they're living there in the
summer you'll be able to use it
yes it would be big enough for both of
us to be there in the summer and we
would utilize it in the winter too and
you've got kids
yes sir known as their grandkids
yeah and it's i'm like
this is great they're smart people okay
so you don't but you don't have the
other 200 grand
no not yet okay how long before you have
that
honestly it would probably take us
uh you know four to five years before we
got that well probably closer to four
okay
well lake house is a toy and i'm not
going in debt for a toy so
um and when i bought my lake house many
many many many years ago i didn't go in
debt for it
it's a total okay and so no no you don't
you got out of debt
yeah no i i get it uh it's
it's uh
what's your income i guess
uh so my wife and i make about 140 000 a
year okay you don't have any payments so
i'm going what does it look like to
start looking once we have 100 grand and
they can put in
you know they put in 100 and we start
looking at more affordable options for
lake houses and if it's not the right
one then we keep waiting until we have
the cash to do it and we can pony up 50
and 50.
yeah it's just really tough as far as
getting something that we want in that
price range at this point in time but no
i get where you're coming from is there
any urgency around this no he just wants
a lake house
well of course i want a lake house
who doesn't want a lake agreed i agree
i'm with you i'm 100 with you on that
three years of delaying this dream
you'll live right well or do it in some
other way but here's the thing
because it because it's in a sense
they're they're putting the money on the
table now and that's pushing the urgency
to do it now and then and the fact that
it's a lake house and you're getting
half of the equity covered for you
it seems ludicrous not to borrow the
money to do it but i still am not going
to borrow the money to do a toy i'm
sorry dude i wouldn't do it
um okay if i were you you asked what i
would do and um and i can verify that i
would not do that because i did not do
that i saved up and paid cash because
you know again you're in michigan your
summers are short
and so you got three four months of use
a year
and you know and you're gonna pay
payments on it 12 months
so no
i um
i wouldn't do that now um
what is these folks net worth
i have no clue
well if you were gonna guess 10 million
a million
oh
i
over a million but i i don't know beyond
that okay
so basically this money will be coming
from the sale of their michigan house
yeah probably yeah
okay
um
maybe they go by the lake house
when they sell it
the one that you all agree that you want
and you delay you and you say okay
i'd like to lock in that i can buy it
for half of that
uh when i can save up the money in a few
years meantime
you know we'll all use it together right
yeah it's you know we were just looking
at this as an option it was proposed and
yeah you know so it's a wonderful deal
here in the summer it's a wonderful gift
and a lot of things but listen if you
add up the payments on 200 000
for the number of times that you're
there
uh it's expensive you could go on some
really nice vacations it's expensive and
so um
yeah i i
i want you to be able to figure out a
way to do it but if it involves you
going into debt i'm i would not
personally do that and i would not
recommend it and i love the idea of you
having a lake house i love the idea of
them paying for half of it i love all
these ideas but i'm not ever going to
tell somebody go in debt for a toy and
this is it now on the real estate side
dave if the in-law is by the lake house
and he wants to buy them out of it what
is the right way to do that later they
could just deed it over to him okay he
hands them a check for 200k they buy a
400 000 lake house and
agree that when he ends them 200k they
hand him a deed
um and he starts saving his 200k and
buys them out in a few years on the same
deal plan just gives me a lot of peace
that's what you said i'm thinking papa
and granny here have some money but i
could be wrong that they might be able
to afford it in cash i don't know i
don't know if they can or not yeah um if
they're sitting on two or three four
million dollar net worth 400 grand is
not going to kill them
and they would plan on gifting this
anyway and so on so yeah but no question
no i would not tell you to borrow money
thanks for the call open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
once you get out of that
once i got out of that
and i felt the freedom
there wasn't anything gonna get me back
in
but i had some temptations like he has
had over the years
you know we had a building the first
office building that we had we leased it
for five years
and i had an option to purchase it for
five million dollars when i did the deal
i didn't have any money hardly i mean i
had a net worth but i know five million
dollars
and i'm leasing it for five years well
during that time the building becomes
worth about 14 million wow and you still
have the opportunity right to buy it for
five million
and for five years i'm at four years and
some change and i'm scratching nickels
out of the corner of the couch trying to
get the 5 million together because i
don't want to miss this i was tempted
to to not walk away from all that equity
that was built into this option deal to
go borrow money
i'm borrowing money
i'm not borrowing money it's a sign from
god i'm not supposed to have it if i
don't have the money it's a simple thing
for me this is the ramsey show